Today we have a very special guest.
All three seasons of her series, Odd Mom Out,
just dropped on Peacock.
Well, she's always my dear friend
and my children's aunt
and one of the most important people in my life.
It's actress and comedian, Jill Kargman.
(applause)
Thank you.
I love you.
Okay, so we're gonna do some Thanksgiving
based new stories.
Great.
Based.
Basted.
I see what you did there.
Okay.
Across the country, many first time turkey cooks
are tackling their very first bird.
(mock turkey gobbling)
And wow, there is a lot of messing up going around.
Did I thaw that enough?
When do I bast?
Did I get all the goop out
or did I leave some goop in?
(goofy warbling)
So, CNN reports that Whole Foods
has teamed up with Progressive
to offer turkey insurance this year.
It's like.
These two companies were like,
what's one thing we can control?
If you bought a Whole Foods bird
and suffer a turkey fail,
you can get a $35 Whole Food gift card back
all you have to do is send in the receipt
and a photo and description of your terrible turkey.
Jill, what are you doing for Thanksgiving?
I'm supporting local restaurants
by ordering everything and cooking nothing.
But we're all getting a Turkey Day surprise this week
from Zoom.
CNET reports Zoom is lifting their 40 minute limit
on calls all day long Thursday.
So if you're planning to use the 40 minute limit
as an excuse to keep it short.
Time to find another excuse.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, that's awkward.
Blame it on the bladder.
(audience laughing)
Gotta go.
Well, okay.
So if your turkey goes wrong, you got insurance.
If you want to avoid your family,
now there's no excuses.
Next.
It's been the most challenging year
but people around the country are still giving back
and I love this story so much from Kansas.
A barber named Nate Rivera
is offering haircuts for Turkeys
for the second year in a row.
Donate a turkey, get a free haircut.
And this years different though.
Covid has shut down his barber shop
but Nate and his wife, Erica,
are still collecting turkeys and sides
for their families who need them
and in return, Nate's offering a voucher,
a promise for a haircut when his shops reopens.
(applause)
Stories like this, they really inspire me
and they're exactly what I wanted to do this program for
and if you're looking for more ways to donate this season,
go to our website.
We've got some great ways to give back.
All right, and finally.
Jill, you actually brought something.
I did.
So I wanted to get you a traditional Thanksgiving dessert
to enjoy and this looks like a normal cake
but I would say why stop at one dessert
when you can have many?
So introducing, everybody, the Piecakein.
It's the Turducken of Thanksgiving sweets.
If you lift your cloche.
This is a cloche!
It is a cloche.
It's part pecan pie in a pumpkin pie
in a spice cake with apple pie filling
all in cinnamon butter crumb
with some o'crumble up on it.
Oh my.
(applause)
I want to get everything all in one bite,
the way nature intended.
It's much better than a Turducken.
Oh my god.
Sweets on sweets are better than meats on meats.
Oh my gosh!
That is so good.
Usually on shows, I see people eating garbage
and I'm like, how do they force feed that?
But I'm genuinely inhaling this.
(audience laughing)
I just want to thank Jill.
I love you.
You have a whole other Piecakein on deck.
(audience laughing)
And I just want to say something.
As a cast member myself on Odd Mom Out.
Yes, you were so good.
It was the best time ever
and I love this show so much.
I loved being a part of it
and I really loved watching it.
So nice.
Well, I love you.
Love you.
And to everyone out there,
eat, enjoy, be happy, be healthy, be safe.
(upbeat music)